Let me walk you through ChatGPT. This is a new addition to ChatGPT. It did have the ability
to search before, but it's gotten a lot better and it looks at multiple sources. Let me just
search here for who won the election. It gives us the right answer now because it has up-to-date
information from the searches it did. It gives us a specific credit to the sources which
is useful. In this case, it's on the Wall Street Journal and you can see here a bit more information.
Now if you look on citations, it shows this one specifically. There's also other ones
as well, so you can look at Arroyo's, click through specifically to see this. Now, the
interesting thing that I found is even if you turn the search off, you say, who won
the election? I will still do a search, so it's actually, I think as we speak right
now, it's not actually possible to turn this feature off. It will bring this in regardless
whenever you're asking for some to-date information, but it is quite useful. Now, if you want to
turn the search off, you could go into neutral and then if you just to judge it in classic,
you can say the election and it tells us it actually refuses. It's fun, but let's see
a very hot topic. That's probably why it appears interesting. So that's how the search works.
I would say it's useful, especially for specific situations where you need up-to-date information.
Another good example here is what are the latest trends amongst teens?
It's street fashion. Because it searches multiple articles, it can be quite useful and it can even
bring back images and they can summarize all these different things. So here it's looking at
the in-style, college fashion, a few different sites, and you can click through and see
the validation here if it's any good. The other thing I found it useful for is restaurants and
is a restaurant meeting that sells and tries. Because it has your IP address, it will actually
do a search for you. Unfortunately, it's not very accurate because it's just based on IP
and I don't live in Birmingham, but that's where my IP address is. It is pretty good. It gives you
back a map here, a list, so really gunning for Google here. But again, I would recommend you
click through to check if search results first. Hopefully, that's useful. It's much better than
the previous search, which would only search maybe one thing at a time. So I've been using this more
than a month. So I think it's really useful.